Hãy bỏ đi
Hãy biệt
Hãy tiền
Hãy bỏ đi
Sao bỏ đi, là cái đi, là trị cà
Hãy bỏ đi, là kéo là tụi bỏ đi
Chỉ biết là bỏ đi, là không?
Trình, nhau, tụi bỏ đi đây
Chỉ là kia, nó mấy nhạm
Mà ra, nó mỏ ngôn
Mà ra, sẽ ta yên
Ba ra, không bỏ
Đóng qua 2 bà tháng 1 năm enemy khu chem ai mi southwest
Hí xíu chuyện qua khu được nước sau linh tình
H Throughn researching bà co tốc phát bình K contained 3 người đình ông ở bắt bên
Anh hốn anh cứ Và Anh 2
Nhất được 1 bà tải chương một tỷ đồng ở về đường
Ý xo sao?
Ng impressed hôm BY 5 đếm ở để 100 sột tiền đã được hệ được với các anh
Chứ đó, người này như account rucm phi kìm xa cà mẹ ra zo thông
Và vấn khí h这里 chứ cũng có ăn dương lại tại vì chị có bao tải
Đi trong hình hoàn về Ban hủng ai
Nó phụ nước đã gặp anh vẫn và anh cường tệ một quán có phê ơn giá tất lục, bất nền lại tàn bộ số tiền trước sự chân kiến của mình dân địa phương.
Huyện lại tài sản, nghe này nói chính sắc số tiền, mẹng giá chung bao tài, đồng thời viết cảm kết,
quay video và cũng có tùng tiền cần cơ cộng dân.